heads with us in Orlando hi Ted your
question for crisp yes sir thank you
very much Dave and Chris for taking my
call the pressures are with you guys
sure I've been putting the numbers I
would like to retire in 13 years at 51
according to the rrq all I need is 1,600
hours a month to get me going for my
question is how many years once you put
the numbers and the amount that I need
to contribute okay how many years for
the last okay now Ted one of the things
you want to remember is as you start to
do this and you start this conversation
with yourself with your spouse on riq
is you understand that as you're
investing you're going to have as what
Dave and I were talking about earlier
the power of compound interest so the
money that you're investing is always
going to keep growing for you alright
and so what you want to do is again as
you sit down with an endorsed local
provider talk about what's your plan
what's your withdrawal rate how much are
you going to have to live off of and
remember the one thing we're never going
to take into retirement with us is debt
so if you're still paying on a house or
if you're doing any of that
remember you're going to attack that
stuff and watch your cost of living drop
down it's going to drastically decrease
how much you have to have which
increases the amount of time and amount
of money that you'll have in the long
haul okay so you got you you ran the riq
Ted and you have a number that you're
going to want at retirement a big number
what was that number correct I put 1,600
a month and currently I have $90,000 and
contributing close to $1,000 a month I
believe was somewhere at five or six
thousand six hundred thousand right and
then you wanted you wanted to withdrawal
you wanted to withdraw sixteen hundred a
month correct like early I get twelve
from the employer and I'm contributing
fifteen so I'm probably more steps
I have only eight years left in the
mortgage we don't have any other debt
however my wife loves to work and she's
probably going to work until six sixty
one with my past experience I would love
to do more of you know traveling and
helping through church so all I need is
I'm very frugal all I need is sixteen
hundred dollars buy a brand-new car
before I retire at 51 and if I have to
give four or five days out of the week
you know do a silencer work to church
that's kind of like my dream and then
take care of my wife when she got home
kids going to be grown so the only thing
is I'm having a hard time is if I'm uh
if I should be okay with the $1,600 I
didn't go to it yet but only eight
percent gain how many years according to
the are IQ doesn't have that question I
know it'll run perpetually if you said
if you set the restore all right and you
set the investment right and you hit
both of those it will run forever that's
how it's set up
so my my goal was at fifty one I have a
457 so I should use the 457 because I
don't want to pay the 10% feed before
your exile and a half exact and then if
I run out of the 457 it's going to be by
then only according to the IQ 125,000
I'm going to start getting into the Roth
and get in the remaining the money that
I put in and then by then I'm leaving
the 401 all the way hopefully by 61-62
my only concern is will they be okay
instead of me doing 27 percent to be in
the safe tried to put maybe 37 percent
and not go extremely of pain'll vows at
a faster pace no you need to stick a 15%
and pay off the house is what res was
telling a minute ago yeah you got to
attack that another thing I'm gonna
encourage him to do Dave as he's talking
about he wants to travel and do some
mission work he's gonna have to revisit
how much he's going to have to live on
each and every month and so taking a
looking at that dollar amount and just
realistically understanding what you
want to do is start the conversation get
out all your statements the 401k 457 s
all of those things go sit down with the
professional that can walk you through
the process and help he and his wife get
their money on the same page yeah so you
know when you're going to use the 457
when you're going to use the 401 K and
the trick is the big number that you've
got there the total of those things if
they are earning what you put into the
tool and you're withdrawing what you put
into the tool that that lump of money
will last even if you're drawing a
little bit on the 404 57 at the start
then after we get over 59 and a half you
start drawing on the other it doesn't
matter which one you're taking it from
because it's still a pile of money that
you're drawing
against but again those investment
assumptions that you put in there and
those withdrawal assumptions are always
going to take you to infinity as far as
it'll last you're not going to run out
of money is how that thing's set up we
don't want it to where you're trying to
take it to zero I I guess you could
manipulate that tool to where you
withdrew more than the investment amount
wasn't it would take it it would
eventually drain it yeah yeah and so
some people have used that as they start
to talk about estate planning Dave
things money they want to leave to kids
or grandkids or whatever it is but like
I said it's the conversation starter so
for you to start to get intentional with
it and are guaranteed Ted as he starts
to look at this and he runs the numbers
he's going to get serious about
attacking that house because he's going
to realize the mortgage payment that
he's making right now he could be paying
himself in his future exactly very good
Ryan's with us in Colorado Springs Ryan
your question for Chris Hogan hey
hey David Chris my name's Ryan Graham
funny colorspace currently have no debt
side of the house are we old 220,000 on
the house and our yearly incomes about
$9,000 and with a baby on the way now my
company puts up on an unmatched 14%
retirement for for us is that something
I should be adding to and and an
additional two I know 15% kind of a the
number I don't know that we are putting
14% into what into a retirement what
kind of retirement that's what I don't
know you're not very good with the whole
you need to find out if it's a pension
or if it's if they're putting that much
into your 401k my guess is it's a
pension I think that sound familiar
yeah you need to learn about that number
one and then your question is what my
question is should I put in an
additional two that addition more than
14% than their what they're putting away
absolutely see as you sat down and
you're looking at this as you hit baby
step number four you want to make sure
that you yourself as you sit down you
and your wife and talking about it and
you're looking you understand what
they're doing but you want to stay
focused on what you're doing and
especially as your family's expanding
here you got a baby coming on the way
you want to be intentional with this you
want to make sure you're setting your
money aside as you look at it and David
I just hope you four years 15 percent
you want that there in your 401k and
it's you putting in 14 percent of your
15 percent of your money perfect and so
if you've got a you know you guys
sitting down together looking at that if
they're doing that I want you to know
exactly what they're doing for you go
see HR go get your benefit specialist
get that packet go sit down with an ALP
and understand exactly what it's being
invested in and when and how you can
control it Chris has a bit of a busy
fall Chris Hogan is my guest this
half-hour and he and I will be doing the
smart money tour together we'll be in
Baton Rouge and Atlanta in Nashville in
Oklahoma City and in Louisville this
fall at September October and November
and he'll be doing his new retire
inspired event in three cities Kansas
City in Denver and in Oklahoma City in
November and early December and he and
Rachel my daughter Rachel Cruz will be
doing a smart money event in Cincinnati
in October as well and Chris and I will
be doing the smart conference together
in Phoenix and in Denver in October so a
little bit of airline miles coming up
for you sir there we are going to be all
over the place Dave but the thing that I
love about it is that wherever we go
we're bringing hope we're bringing real
world education to people so they can
understand how they can take control of
their financial futures and get serious
about their results and that's what I
want people to do I don't want you to
listen to the news and don't listen to
all the people that tell you you can I
want you to stay focused and control the
things you can control
your attitude your outlook and your
output you can do this for tickets to
those events Dave Ramsey calm or call
customer care a triple a 22-piece triple
eight two two seven three two two three
and I'm holding the advanced readers
copy for chris's book that's coming out
in January it's not for sale yet but
it's a it's going to be a big book y'all
and we're really exciting the baby is in
the house man it's good stuff thanks for
coming by Chris thank you for having me
sir good stuff Chris Hogan 360 dot-com
Dave Ramsey calm for tickets and info on
all that stuff this is the Dave Ramsey
show